we are bringing people here we are we
are competing with other state there's I
think 7 or 9 s state in a net they say
that offer zero income tax and what what
is amazing is what they find what they
find when they can come here and they
see that every single I heard about
reporting is not true the Puerto Rico is
now lifting is again in any way up and
and they are putting their money here do
you have Nick Brown t do you have John
Paulson you have many people many
important people in there in the
financial world in the United State
investing huge money important what
happens with your relationship with the
United States government when you have
guys like John Paulson so publicly
investing so big in Puerto Rico and you
could have politicians in New York like
Chuck Schumer picking up the phone and
saying John you leave this state we're
going to have a problem are you ready to
hurt your relationship with US
politicians no I think it's a
competition issue what I should do when
a company from Puerto Rico go to you can
beat zero call an offer of New York they
are competing they want to compete we
want to compete and I let me tell you
something I hate to compete I just like
the winner talk to me about act 2022 in
comparison to what the Virgin Islands
has offered for the last fourteen years
because they tried and it never really
took off why is it working here then you
have a very good example there that they
our friends our neighbors a USVI they
try for 14 years and know no one's
took a look at it and put Rico is now
competing we have a little more to offer
because Puerto Rico is even though it's
135 miles island it's like like a
continent you have rainforests you have
you have beaches you have many thing to
see here and many thing to do here so we
are succeeding what does it mean for
wealthy Puerto Ricans though with the
2022 Americans can be here for six
months and one day and then their tax
inheritance is completely exempt for all
investments you
when if a Puerto Rican buy something
outside Puerto Rico they're gonna be
faced with a big tax is that fair well
the fact is that these people is
bringing wealth to Puerto Rico and
that's good for everybody here for the
wealth class or and for the and for the
poorest class in Puerto Rico let's do
the banner will rather be hotel for
example no one we're about to vote that
and your postage came and didn't save
the game for that asset a lot of Puerto
Rican so there is investment getting to
shore because they had this investor
that that came here we need to share
wealth not poverty we need to bring
wealth to Puerto Rico we need to create
wealth to have wealth to share the other
way is to share poverty and I'm not here
to share poverty I'm here to share
wealth